at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by peloton which I've
been using probably for about a year now
peloton is a cutting-edge indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home you can also do
on-demand which is what I do we'll come
back to that so you don't have to worry
about fitting classes into a busy
schedule or making it to a studio or gym
with a hectic or unpredictable commute I
for instance have a peloton bike right
in my master bedroom at home and it's
one of the first things I do many
mornings I wake up I meditate for a bit
then I knock out a short 20 minute ride
in my undies hard to do that at the gym
take a shower and I'm in higher gear for
the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on-demand
and listen to a lot of and watch many of
the same classes over and over but I'm
kind of promiscuous and also enjoy
classes from a lot of the other
instructors they have peloton and
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyze you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way incentivize me
but they really 100% hit the nail on
and I was very very impressed with how
motivating it was I know work
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me
so check it out discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings the studio experience right to
your home peloton is offering listeners
of this podcast a limited time offer go
to one peloton calm that's o-n-e peloton
PE l oto and calm and enter the code Tim
all caps at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your policy I could
purchase so get a great workout at home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started this episode is brought to you
by audible which has the largest
selection of audiobooks on the planet
I've used audible for many years and I
have several audio books to recommend
right off the bat if you're looking for
a new one ready player one by Ernest
Cline you may have heard of it the town
of Seneca by Seneca if you want to hear
my favorite collection of letters of all
time as well as the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman which is a fiction book I
used to reintroduce nonfiction purists
to the beauty and truth and enjoyment of
fiction the graveyard book it is
incredible and I like the version that
Neil reads himself but the entire
ensemble cast is also fun audible
members get a credit every month good
for any audiobook you the store
regardless of price and unused credits
roll over to the next month so if you
didn't like your audiobook no problem
you can exchange it no questions asked
plus your books are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and relist in
anytime even if you cancel your
membership and for some books again
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman
I've listened many many times you may
even just start over as soon as you
finish it the first time audible also
helps you to listen to more books by
letting you switch seamlessly between
devices picking up exactly where you
left off whether it's on your phone
through your car from a tablet or at
home on an Amazon echo whatever you can
get through tons of books hands and eyes
free while doing almost anything
that is part of the beauty of audio it
is a secondary activity when you are
walking the dog cooking whatever it
might be audible content includes an
unmatched selection of audio books
original audio shows news comedy and
much more from leading audio book
publishers broadcasters entertainers
magazine and newspaper publishers and
business information providers maybe
that's what I am a business information
provider and right now audible is
offering listeners of this podcast a
free audio book with a 30-day trial
memberships check it out go to
audible.com forward slash tim and browse
the unmatched selection of audio
programs download a title free and start
listening it is super simple go to
audible.com forward slash tim or text
tim to 500 500 on your telephone to get
started today check it out hello boys
and girls this is tim ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers
people who are the best at what they do
to tease out the routines the life
lessons the habits the favorite books
whatever it might be that you can
hopefully apply and test in your own
life my guest today is Paul Stamets
hundreds maybe thousands of people have
requested that I have Paul on the show
you can find him on Instagram Facebook
and YouTube Paul Stamets sta M ETS he is
an intellectual and industry leader in
the habitats medicinal use and
production of fungi that's fu ng i fungi
some people say and you might also think
of mycelium or mushrooms part of his
mission is to deepen our understanding
of and respect for the organisms that
literally exist under every footstep
taken on this path of life this episode
is bonkers the implications applications
medicinal uses of many of the things
that he'll discuss are truly
mind-boggling and we do get into some of
my favorite subjects including
psychedelics and other aspects of
bending reality here we go back to the
bio Paul is the author of six books
including mycelium running subtitle how
mushrooms can help save the world
growing gourmet and medicinal mushrooms
and psilocybin mushrooms of the world he
has discovered and named numerous new
species of psilocybin mushrooms
psilocybin mushrooms or SaLuSa bee
mushrooms better known as magic
mushrooms and is the founder and owner
of fungi perfecti makers of the host
defense mushroom supplement line and a
little-known fact I have been using host
defense products for a few years now
after Cimino Sarat said that one of them
was her favorite purchase of less than a
hundred dollars in the last year or two
and that was in my last book travel
mentors so I do have some familiarity
with his products paul has received
numerous awards including invention
ambassador for the American Association
for the Advancement of science the
National mycologist award from the North
American mycological Association and the
Gordon and Tina Watson award from the
mycological Society of America his
Instagram is awesome if you want to see
some really really really weird fungi
and him off in the woods all over the
world doing weird things and in very new
and breaking news we were actually
holding the podcast waiting for this to
happen Paul is the author of a new study
in Nature scientific reports which
details how mushroom extracts
specifically extracts from woodland
polypore mushrooms can greatly reduce
viruses that contribute to be colony
collapse this is a huge huge huge deal
and we do get into the importance of
bees and how without bees pretty much
everything goes down the toilet by
including a lot of humanity so I will
include a link in the show notes which
you can always find at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast for everyone who
wants to check that out and two other
announcements if you are interested as I
am and I'm certainly committed to this
to the tune of seven figures over the
next year to two supporting psychedelic
science and research please join me and
if you're interested in doing so at a
higher dollar amount meaning over a
hundred thousand dollars please go to
Tim log forward slash science that's Tim
DUP log forward slash
science and if you want to support at
lower dollar amounts checkout maps dot
org and for anyone who has already
filled out that form I will be reaching
out soon and there's a lot of amazing
stuff on the horizon that I hope you'll
be involved with and last but not least
the blog now contains transcripts of
every podcast episode to date people
have been asking for this for a long
long time I want to do it right so now
you can find transcripts to every
episode of the podcast at Tim vlog
forward slash transcripts and that is a
long intro so without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with Paul Stamets and if you can only
listen to one part jump ahead about 49
minutes or so 49 minutes and 50 seconds
I believe but yeah let's call 49 minutes
to listen to his description of his
first experience with solicit be
mushrooms or psilocybin containing
mushrooms and the effect it had on his
lifelong stutter it is [ __ ] nuts so
if you're gonna skip around jump ahead
49 minutes or so and listen to that
story it is really really wild so there
you have it enjoy Paul welcome to the
show thank you Tim honored to be here
I've had so many listeners request you
on the show I have wanted to have you on
the show for so many years and finally
when you made your very comprehensive
cameo and Michael Pollan's most recent
book that served as the reminder that I
had to reach out somehow so I'm very
pleased that you're here and I thought
we could start with some definitions and
pronunciation which are very selfishly
points of insecurity for me so if you ng
I how should we pronounce that well
excellent question fungi according to
Oxford English Dictionary with a J is
the correct pronunciation but Fuji a
fungi or fungi so fungi is what else
mycologist use though people spanish
mycologists will use Fuji
you know Italian mycologist will say
Fuji but English speakers the standard
pronunciation is fungi with a J fungi
and then there are two terms that I
suspect may not be totally synonymous
we have mushrooms and my cilium or
mycelium I don't know the correct
pronunciation our mushrooms a subset of
mycelium one component part can you
define or distinguish those two for us
please the mycelium is the underground
network analogous to the roots of a tree
and the fruit bodies are the mushrooms
so they are produced as a reproductive
structures long after many challenges on
the path of growth in the wood in woods
underground etc the mycelial networks
are vast
it's been called the proverbial tip of
the iceberg but just think of this as
the the mycelium navigates through micro
really hostile environment literally
there can be tens of millions of
microbes per gram of soil and the my
silly old yz5 the fine filaments that
look like cobwebs are running
underground and this underground network
is being challenged by all sorts of
microbes and as many people know that
bacteria like to eat fungi that's why
mushrooms rot but the fungi are able to
navigate with these mycelial networks
only one cell wall thick and they can be
up to 8 miles of mycelium per cubic inch
and now they only have one cell wall
between their their internal cells and
the external environment we have five or
six skin layers that protect us from
infection that my silly mat basically
has one cell layer and yet is able to
overcome the challenges of millions of
microbes many of which want to consume
it and it navigates to create the
largest organism on this planet as a
mycelial mat in eastern oregon over
2,200 acres in size now it's one cell
wall thick and yet it's the largest
organism on this planet
and that's a testimonial to the
immunological power of the mycelium and
this vast underground network that is so
central to habitat and human and plant
health is something that we have really
tapped into
so mushrooms come from mycelium the
mycelium can grow literally for decades
before single mushroom eons mushrooms
are highly perishable they're like fish
four or five days they mature and then
they rot and then in doing so they spoil
eight just before they rot may attract
insects that are then help spread the
spores much like you know birds spread
seeds and the birds come to fruit the
fruit of the tree like a peach for
instance attracts insects and birds and
then the peach pit or seeds of an apple
or another fruit are spread so the
fragrance of the mushrooms are beacons
fragrance beacons that emanate through
the ecosystem and these scent trails and
entice animals that come to these
bodacious lis delicious fruit bodies and
then they send in the course of them
eating them they spread the spores but
the mycelium literally can be existent
seemed not not invisible invisible to us
ridiculously stupid humans that are
thundering Giants upon these networks
that are underneath their feet but the
mycelium really races behind us and
we're the biggest walk-in catastrophe
that I know on the planet and as we walk
we break woodchips we leave impressions
well the mycelium is sensitive to those
impressions of our footsteps and as we
create new debris fields the mycelium
reaches up behind our footsteps to
gobble up that newly made material and
competition with other fungi and other
organisms and mycelium if we're looking
at mycelium and as one component of that
or rather not the product of that I
suppose and please feel free to correct
me if I screw things up by restating
mushrooms people have had a decent
amount of exposure to and they tend to
associate it with say the produce aisle
in a grocery store and think of them
perhaps as plants from a genetic
perspective or an evolutionary
perspective how should people think
about mycelium I love this question well
you bring up a very good point for for
almost a hundred year
now the mycology departments were a
subset of botany departments they really
should be in these zoology departments
we separated from fungi about 650
million years ago six hundred and fifty
million years ago we had a common
ancestor in fact there's a new super
Kingdom called a Pais LeConte ah that
joins a fungi and Animalia together when
basically these nice little networks
when when they hit the land from the
ocean
many people don't realize some of the
largest networks of mycelium in the
world now I've been discovered in below
the sediment layers of the ocean is vast
my cell networks throughout the entire
ocean there's lots of dead organic plant
material that's falling down to the
sediments and the mycelium is involved
in gobbling those up but from an
evolutionary point of view a 650 million
years ago we chose the path of in
circulating our nutrients basically in a
cellular sac a stomach the mycelium
digest nutrients externally it produces
the enzymes and acids and other
compounds that break down complex
organic molecules and then absorbs those
through the cell walls the entire
mycelial network is as like a sponge it
absorbs selectively those nutrients that
it needs and animals went sort of over
ground and we developed these digestive
systems and I in a protective skin
enveloped structure or bodies and then
the mycelium continuous course very
happily developing underground
so with the divergence of fungi and and
animals as being extremely well
documented but an extraordinary article
came out just this past year and this
article you know the the the Big Bang is
about 13.8 billion years ago the earth
formed around 4.5 billion years ago the
first unicellular organisms were found a
few hundred million years later but the
first multicellular organisms so far
found the oldest one is 2.4 billion
years ago that has found in South
African law
in the basalt and it's 2.4 billion years
old the oldest representation so far in
the fossil record of a multicellular
organism and these are my silly old
networks so the mycelium had its form
long before we've had ours and moreover
in Brazil 150 115 million years ago this
is before the great extinction event
that killed off the dinosaurs and at
that time mushrooms also had their forms
so these mushrooms are really ancient
organisms they had developed or forms
long before we had developed ours we are
descended from these fungal networks
they are progenitor ancestors we are we
are really descendants of fungi this is
why under the microscope so many of our
cells look so similar to that a fungi
and also why our best antibiotics that
we have coming from funds are very good
at preventing bacteria from growing but
we have very very few good antifungal
antibiotics because of our close
evolutionary history that are not toxic
or highly toxic to us so antifungal
drugs are extremely dangerous those
who've had immunosuppressants are well
aware of this and when you defeat the
immune system of the human body using
immuno suppressants for organ
transplants and other reasons and and
medicine you're really dancing with
death because it's extremely damaging to
your immune system that can hold many of
these infections that they there are so
many directions that I want to go with
this I'm going to try to contain my ad D
and focus this in a direction towards
another type of utility and relates to a
problem that if I were to walk 15 feet I
could observe with my own eyes right now
and that is carpenter ants and I was
wondering if you could talk about your
history with carpenter ants in the
intersection with mycelium is a
something
dear to my heart so well let me I'm
gonna I'm in a segue because there could
be listeners out there who have children
and I'm gonna tell their children to the
story how vacuuming and helping your
mother and your parents made me over a
million dollars and it ties in the
carpenter ants so um I grew up in it so
I'm gonna need two minutes to set this
up I mean we have all the time in the
world okay
so I grew up in a small town in Ohio
Columbiana Ohio a very conservative town
about 5,000 people and I grew up in a
fairly wealthy household my family had
steel mills and sawmills and we were
affluent we had four hundred people in
the town under unemployment of a town of
about five thousand so the statements
Enterprise company unfortunately because
of after World War two we bombed you
know we bombed Japan we bombed Germany
but they retooled they rebuilt our
factories they had modern factories
after the war in the United States we
didn't do that and so the machine tool
industry really fell apart in the early
1960s there's a huge economic downturn
and so I was the best experience of my
life was the fact that I grew up in a
wealthy environment and then I was 10 or
11 years of age the entire financial
empire collapsed we lost everything and
we laid off over 400 people in the town
were laid off I'm going to school these
these kids and their parents you know
are not very happy about what was
happening it was really devastating to
us and my parents separated and we lived
in this big house the electricity was
cut off the water was cut off I remember
eating cat food I was just so hungry
gave me tremendous farts but uh but I my
mom was really desperate my brother John
went on to Yale my brother bill was that
Cornell and this is you know towards the
end of their college experiences and I
was there home alone with my mother and
my twin brother and I just really had to
step up their plate to help my mother as
much as possible I remember running a
hose from our neighbor's about 500 feet
of hose just to get 2 or 3 psi so we
could trickle feed into the toilet
I've been flush them it was really
strange in the lead bewildering sort of
Kafka is in existence because we were
shunned by the town my mother went into
religion my dad went into alcohol they
both were self-medicating in a sense no
there was two avenues um but I got
really good at helping my mom vacuum
because she needed help and we didn't
have you know the support team we had
anymore so I was always like tearing
apart vacuum cleaners and borrowing
parts and trying to get get and trying
to help my mom any way I could so I
vacuum vacuum vacuum and I got I'm
really still passionate about vacuuming
there's only my I'm a really good house
husband I like washing dishes and
vacuuming a lot so how this works a ways
in the carpenter ants is the is the
following so I grew up in and you know
in this affluent environment it came out
the Washington state became a logger
hippie for three years you know working
in the woods then moved outside of
Olympia Washington I went to the
Evergreen State College and I tried to
start this little business and I lived
in a house at dr. Andrew Weil said is
the worst house he's ever seen anyone
live in in North America that's one
statement it was a flat flat house built
with military surplus materials and I
had 12 buckets catching water from the
flat roof why need to build a flat roof
in Washington the state with army
surplus materials there's another
question but there's so many leaks that
I just keep on putting up buckets and
then one day I remember there's a storm
and and the house fell like 2 or 3
inches and my wife was my god the house
is falling I said don't worry dear we
don't have to fill the buckets as much
because the water will rot faster I was
just trying to be able to be optimistic
because I was afraid that she was gonna
get up and leave me because the
conditions were so bad but anyhow I
would be making my espresso in the
morning and and I looked over in the
corner and there's a pile of sawdust
from carpenter ants and I see them
running around and the carpenter ants
are more nocturnal than they are you
know active in the daytime and so I'd
make my espresso every morning I look
over the palace I suppose the vacuum
cleaner to vacuum it up I did the next
day and the next day and the next day I
do this for hundreds of days realizing
the house is getting more
less structurally sound with the
carpenter ants and munching them and so
I was not gonna do something about this
and so you know I don't want to use raid
I didn't want to use you know toxic
insecticides because the war against
nature in my mind is a war against your
own biology and there was toxic to other
organisms is likely toxic to you and
this has been well founded now with lots
of examples so I wanted an Environmental
Protection Agency homepage and I looked
up a group of fungi that would attack
ants and these are called intimal
pathogenic fungi so mouthful but anthem
Oh meets insects and pathogenic means of
course causing disease of insects and
this group of enzyme a pathogenic fungi
that was particularly of interest and
supported by scientific literature and
with a encouragement of the EPA with a
group of fungi in the genus meta RISM so
meta and Rhys iam you know lots of
mycelium lots of rice and works and so I
looked into this group of meta regime
fungi non-toxic the bees non toxic to
fish non toxic to humans
and I I got some of these fungi and I
started growing them out now I started
studying this well this is really
interesting why isn't it's not available
everywhere
why isn't there Lowe's and Home Depot
and Walmart why aren't they selling this
well for very good reason the insects
aren't stupid when you see insects like
carpenter ants and are constantly
cleaning themselves they're trying to
get the spores of the fungus off of them
is the most common fungus according to
some reports in the soil underneath your
feet it is everywhere it is a dance of
dinner and death between insects and
fungi many insects eat fungi many fungi
eat insects the two of them don't like
to be at the dinner table at the same
time so I end up getting this fungus and
I studied it and the reason why I never
came to market is for the spore
repellency property now this is really
important because these insects have
realized that the scent of these spores
meant that there's a disease threat to
the colony so the insects fastidiously
Queen themselves of these spores so when
the big companies like Bear and down
Syngenta tried to make bait stations
using these spores even though in the
laboratory they can dust the insects
from the spores and sure enough five
days later they were killed the insects
the even they probably made bait
stations around people's houses the
insects won't go near those base
stations because there's other spores
and so the spore repellency property
prevented these bait traps from going
into market for preventing termites fire
ramps carpenter ants moisture has all
sorts of ants and termites are infected
by these these these sporulating fungus
matter is iam so I thought well I'm
having laboratory a very large
laboratories we produce about fifty
thousand kilos of mycelium of the many
different gourmet and medicinal
mushrooms per week and my environments
are class 100 clean rooms these are
high-tech clean room environments using
HEPA filters high efficiency
particularly air filters and the last
thing I want is a spoil adding mold in
my laboratories so I got these cultures
and I was shocked
I'm spores they were reminds somebody of
a Penicillium mold you know growing on
cheese you want that flying around your
laboratory because my oyster mushroom
cultures or my shiitake cultures could
become contaminated from airborne spores
so I I cultured this out really quickly
and so the window of exposure was very
short and I set up all these precautions
and then I'm culturing these fungi and
then they go out as green molds and then
I saw this white wedge a v-shaped wedge
that was all white they had no
sporulation on it and I went whoa that's
interesting I looked up in scientific
literature and everybody said oh the
culture is losing the ability to
reproduce is losing the ability to spoil
8 it is senescent avoid sectors this was
a call these wedges or white sectors
because that path of genetic path down
that gene trail will end up meaning the
culture will die they personally got
that right but I was motivated by not
having spores in my laboratory so I
chased those white suckers and then they
grow out in about a week or two weeks
and
on the standard size petri dish and then
after about five or six seven transfers
that white wedge got bigger and bigger
and bigger and pretty soon no
sporulation
and this is current day in your the this
experiment that you were running was is
is done more recently not when you were
under the the flat roof built by
military surplus is that right I'm just
trying to place the front this is this
is synchronous with that with all that
okay got it
so but I had to go out of my laboratory
to have enough mycelium be able to treat
the carpenter rounds gotcha so any other
so I finally threw it out I grew it on
the rice and I made a big deal to my
daughter and I'm so thankful to her for
the reasons you're about to hear and I
made a big deal in the middle of summer
saying we're gonna trick the carpenter
ants because every morning I'm sucking
up all the sawdust and so I asked for a
Barbie doll dish which I still have I'm
gonna mount it in her frame and I put
like 25 kernels of white mycelium on
rice of this metal regime fungus without
spores because they wouldn't go near the
rice of the head spores and I laid it
out around 8:30 at night in the summer
afternoon there was a summer evening and
I made a big deal of it
I'm gonna got my daughter involved you
know as a citizen scientist young she
was only oh my gosh she was probably 14
at the time and so when we went to bed
so thankfully my daughter woke up at 102
o'clock in the morning and she rather
than going straight to the bathroom she
won look at her Barbie doll dish she
went over there talking on licence
swarming with carpenter ants I got oh my
gosh you gotta be kidding
and and so she ran into our bedroom said
dad dusty wake up you've got to see this
and you know we don't want to wake up as
two o'clock in the morning but she
dragged us out of bed we went over there
and was just covered with carpenter ants
they're picking up the rice and they're
going into them into the recesses of a
house disappearing you know like oh my
god that was amazing because I had mice
in the house the mice could have eaten
the rice and I would never have known
but we watched for a few minutes and
they took away all the my ciliated rice
so we fast-forward I'm making my
espresso every morning hundreds of times
I get the vacuum cleaner
that spot there's no solace the
carpenter ants were gone and I went oh
my gosh I just think I figured out a way
to overcome the Spore repellency
property so now this has been elaborated
we published an article in the journal
sociobiology proving this was effective
against subterranean termites Formosan
termites we've done experiments as now
with the USDA and other teams some of
the biggest pesticide companies in the
world
I'm I'd have to check my NDA's to see if
they're still covered or not but
everyone listening can imagine who they
are they tested this it's effective
against bedbugs ants termites thrips
flies mosquitoes
you know mites phenomenal reach and so I
ended up finding something that is a
super attractant and basically the
opposite of Spore repellency property is
the mycelial attractants ii property two
sides of the same coin the yin and yang
of nature is kind of harmonious in that
sense I like that
and we found that if we diluted the
mycelium extracts on rice without the
spores this these continual these pre
continual pre sporulating sectors that I
described we end up creating a super
attractant so powerful that when the
attractant wasn't diluted 500 to one
with water diluting the extract made it
more potent in terms of attractin see
that one experiment two drops of this
print on a pane of glass and fire ants
locked directly to that place and then
scratched at that place until they died
walking about a meter creating a trail
that other than fire ants would follow
so so we have done this now with choices
they're called T tests we've known this
was the the T test or even better T test
often times is you know go left for the
control go right for the treatment but
we ended up doing a four and five choice
experiments where there was only one
corridor or Avenue that had the
treatment and the other ones were all
controls so highly significant activity
and we found something that
I can my dream is be able to to attract
a locust plug into a 55-gallon drum we
can put these in farmers and you know in
Africa and just create a massive huge
huge attractants efactor the cool thing
also the attractants ii is not lethal so
that that that comes later the
infectious state of the mycelium it
grows and then it penetrates the the
exoskeleton with a high full peg it kind
of anchors itself like a sticky little
tongue and then it dissolves the
exoskeleton the chitin and then the -
peg invades into the body of the insect
and it mummifies them so these are many
people heard about these zombie fungi
this is what they are some of them have
a cordyceps representation there's a
little Club fungi and Costa Rica
elsewhere in the subtropics the many of
the ants there are well known for the
leafcutter ants and other ants are known
that they have to get infected with this
fungus they climbed the top canopy of
the trees and they locked their mantle
underneath the leaf and winged mushroom
comes out of their head in their anus
and it's pointless in this way the
fungus gets a spore you light and free
air conditions high up in the canopy so
it causes uncontrolled behavior of
climbing with these insects so this item
its breakthrough and the reason why and
I end up license in this to a group of
investors and I got a million dollars
and so I like to tell my daughter she
was very instrumental in this and the
licensing agreement had some limits on
it they had to take it to market within
five years I pulled back the licensing
agreement and they didn't take it the
market so I pulled it back and
everything exactly quite friendly but
it's a little bit of a mystery why he
did not make it to market and I have a
lot of conspiracy theories as to why it
did not make it to market I hesitate to
mention those but I was given a chunk of
change and I was smart enough to realize
that they can't crush this and that was
a condition this has to come to market
but doesn't come to market then I get
the patent rights back and now I've been
issued nine patents on this people can
go to the US patent homepage and look
them up the latest patents that are
was issued on this two years ago is
really phenomenal because I have patents
on antiviral properties of mycelium and
I had these patents on these intimate
pathogenic fungi for all insects and all
diseases vectored by insects it doesn't
get bigger than that what are there any
types and that there are a number of
different areas I want to dig deeper are
there are there any particular common
viruses or particularly lethal viruses
that you've seen applications for using
mycelium in terms of yeah resistance
were defeating yeah well there's there
there's a lot of examples of that and so
I published an article in the journal
peer-reviewed journal called herbal gram
in June of 2001 summarizing all the
literature and that's been published on
the on the antiviral properties of
mushroom mycelium is a whopping one page
long with like six references adversely
very very little out there well that was
in June of 2001 September 11th 2001
you know 9/11 occurred very quickly the
greatest concern for the US Defense
Department and and biosecurity was the
weaponize of all viruses poxviruses you
know anthrax is a bacterium the anthrax
attacks occurred a few weeks later a
group researchers in the US Defense
Department who were scavenging the
literature saw my article and I said wow
there's some evidence here and they
contacted me because I have a very large
library now they may send large to
people don't have libraries I have about
800 strains of different species of
mushrooms clip many of which collected
from the old-growth forests so some
libraries have 20,000 you know culture
so that I'm small compared to them but
I'm private I'm not not a big
institution and so they said well listen
you you've published some interesting
articles here there's some evidence we
have been this the fund funded by Dick
Cheney and George George Bush ironically
I have a debt of gratitude to
with a Bioshield bio defense programs
called project bio bio defense but then
became known as a bio shield program and
so they elicited my support and then I
began to send them cultures mushrooms
boiled in hot water ethanol extracts of
mushrooms the mycelium that gave rise to
the mushrooms etc excedrin so I ended up
sending out sets of a hundred of these
samples I mean this is for me this is a
coup d'etat
I have government laboratories they'll
give me free research you know on my
extracts and so we started sending this
out and didn't hear from them for a
while and they realize they're really
disorganized it was a new program and I
got a colonel I love - he mention his
name he worked out for Detrick you know
where they have smallpox and you know I
said bio bioweapons facility biohazard
facility the US government where the
most pathogenic bacteria and viruses and
other disease organisms and and so I had
an MD person who was my controller
in Federal Express one day you know
about two months later after I submitted
the extracts dopamine this big package
of research reports on anti pox
properties smallpox properties are
extracts well I mean going through it no
activity no activity
I get the sample number 78 high activity
against poxviruses then a sample 81 high
activity sample 88 high activity whoa
I mean it's like you know you're looking
at not effective and no results in the
first 77 pages you know it's pretty
disappointing then BAM I got really
excited so I called my I called my like
my colonel at Fort Detrick and and I
said results are amazing this exciting
and he goes what results I got the
results that Federal Express has
delivered to me he goes you're not
supposed to get those I am a photocopy
now send them to you he didn't
appreciate the humor but it was a very
very bizarre time and some very very
strange things occurred that at that
time but we ended up finding that those
three
highly active results came from an
old-growth mushroom called a gerakan
gerakan is the longest living mushroom
in the world number one or number two
some debate about that it was
exclusively in the old-growth forests
Northern California Oregon Washington
British Columbia in a few sky islands in
Europe and the Alps asla Slovenia in
Austria on larch trees but it is a
indicator species of an old-growth
forest and those three anti pox results
came from three different separate
strains of a gerakan that i had isolated
from my many adventures in the
old-growth forest so whoa this has got
people very excited
now I I'd love to be taken to the mat
I'm reference driven okay so anybody out
there sceptical of this you can do two
things you can google my name's Stamets
National Public Radio NPR and pox and
you'll see a vetted press release
interview on National Public Radio with
me the former deputy director of the FDA
and the head of one of the research
divisions about shield by defense
program dr. jack see Chris from the
Southern Research University so and then
so because I'm in competition with
pharma and I'm a loan researcher a
little company and I thought well like I
checked into this and I already had this
into my pathogenic fungi patents that
were just you know tremendous
achievements because the entire
pesticide industry missed all that so I
thought well this is novel I should
protect myself so I filed a patent mana
on a gerakan against viruses
particularly poxviruses flu viruses
herpes these are all the other results
that we received these extracts were
highly active against multiple viruses
not pox virus quick question for you is
that prevent for preventative use
curative use both what what is what were
the applications this is Tim where I
have to draw the line because these are
in vitro in vitro tests with human cells
and taking through three different
testing protocols to
a point where the next test is in an in
in vivo model like it was an animal so
this is the best of pharmaceutical drug
discovery that you can go through before
you get it get it go to a living host
these are living human cells in in vitro
not in vivo in vivo means this this is
the you know a small mammal like a mouse
you know a rat you know a monkey or it
goes into human clinical studies so
these are vitro tests in DB even though
we have identified now the molecules
that are active against smallpox we
worked with the University of
Mississippi School of Pharmacy under dr.
semir Ross we did a bow guided
fractionation over many years and we
have identified two new anti pox
molecules more potent than Siddhartha
beer which is the preeminent comparative
antiviral drug control with less
toxicity and more efficacy than sadaqa
vera but that being said there's clearly
an upregulation of the immune system and
so what is the contribution of these
molecules versus operating of the immune
system as a combination of both these
are synergism there's multiple molecules
being engaged multiple immune pathways
this is where you can get lost you
cannot see the forest for the trees
if you end up focusing so much on the
mechanisms of action and don't see the
result if you were infected with these
viruses you don't really don't care
about the mechanism of action you just
want to know whether you can overcome
the virus or not so we have found the
anti pox molecules we have not yet found
the anti flu or the anti herpes
molecules today and I have another
really good example of is specific to
your original question of the mycelium
being active against viruses can I pause
for one quick second see I I have to
know what happened after the lieutenant
call because I imagine someone on his
end had to have their head roll for that
type of security breach mailing fedex to
the wrong place
with those research reports what
happened after that oh my god I don't
have to make up these stories I don't
have to make up many stories are too
good to be true as they are but this is
what happened I was in Canada I'm
speaking to you right now from Cortez
Ireland British Columbia I was up here
on Cortez Island and one of my employees
called up and said Paul there's a
helicopter buzzing around the
laboratories I hope no big deal
helicopters fly over all the time he
goes no it's really low
I go how low and he goes listen he puts
a cell phone up today I can come talk to
him
I go well I go what are the numbers on
the tail he goes there are no numbers as
a Blackhawk military helicopter that's
right on top of the laboratories oh my
god you're kidding I go and this is
right after we got the pox results right
after I talked to the colonel you know
like two weeks later or a week later and
I said okay listen shut down the
business I know I knew immediately you
know the government's gonna screw up
here and they're gonna there and an
abundance of caution they're gonna end
up overstepping their bounds and I said
this is crazy I've already been vetted
I've already been permitted I've already
in dialog with these people and they
they're trying to spook me I mean what's
going on here so I shut down the
business at the time I only had 10
employees now I have a hundred and I
said so shut down the business give the
cultures of a gerakan to several of the
employees I never want to know who has
them you know this these centralized
ourself as a target right now and so I
sucked on the business all the employees
left you know the helicopter still
buzzing around and so the next day I
called up pretty pissed off said to the
colonel saying what is going on you know
and he go got really nervous now he's
got two black eyes right they deliver
the wrong results the right results to
the wrong person and now that one you
know government you know on one hand
doesn't talk to the other and they got
over-exuberant and you know and you know
if terrorists got this technology that
could immunize themselves and their
credit and it's like whatever you know
so anyhow it's funny because we I'm
going to the airport's I got five stars
on every single airline ticket I
joke to my wife here we go again I'm
gonna stop and search you know and then
after this then all those those five
stars got taken away and I streamed
through security of no problem but I was
obviously suddenly on their radar
because I'm I'm non-conventional but the
fact that I'm here today actually makes
me more of a patriotic American than I
was before so anyhow so this is so I
found these Cotton's a patent on on the
garret converses these viruses found it
in 2004 you can look this up go to the
US patent home page you'll see my filing
dates I filed this patent in 2004 2009
11 was 2001 so I had to write the patent
get more research results we got lots
and lots of positive results from the
bio shield program I think they I talked
to when the researchers last year and he
goes do you know that we analyzed 2392
of your samples and I won I'm so glad I
didn't have to pay for that though we
got about 40 excellent hits from my 800
or so cultures that were surprising
which has led into I think a paradigm
shifting solution that for many of the
problems that we face today but I
thought file this patent in 2004 2006
it's not even on the patent application
home page anybody out there who didn't
know about patents usually six months to
a year the patent application shows up
at the uspto.gov website US Patent and
Trademark Office dot gov website and it
didn't show up it's over two years so I
can't hold my patent attorney go on you
know what is going on here he gets ahold
of the Patent Office and the Department
of Defense took the patent out of the
Patent Office because of national
security as it you're kidding that's
kind of a pat on my back I was like well
really you think that's not important
but I said that's not right so we need
an inter government agency trace and a
request and the DoD finally released a
patent to go back into the queue and so
ten years after I submitted a patent
application
you know folks that usually two to three
years you get a ruling ten years after
the ice made of the patent it was
approved that's a long as it it's a long
way the good news is a proven
2014 so I've got 17 years and the whole
thing about patents I mean we would not
be talking today if there weren't
patents people think of me no patents
become open-sourced up for 17 years the
idea is to reward the inventor to
incentivize things to come to market
because a patent that is not practice is
not useful or beneficial to society you
know within that 17 years or outside the
17 years it has to be brought the market
there has to be a commercial incentive
patents are awarded for three reasons
one no prior art no evidence and then
the scientific or popular literature of
anyone saying is having the same idea to
unobvious you want experts saying Paul
Stamets you're full of BS this will
never work
and so I have a message to all my
critics out there I bow and say thank
you you've helped me so much in ways
that you did not intend but I'm really
happy that some people and the third is
usefulness so those are the three things
no prior art contrary to conventional
wisdom you know and and usefulness and
so you know obviously that fits all
three of those categories so that then
the the the Parkes molecules I have not
patents patented they're open-source
hopefully we'll never have a smallpox
epidemic or pandemic again and I think
that's obviously serves a greater good
so another follow-up question that out
of self-interest I'd love to ask related
to the carpenter ants for people who are
eager to try to address something with
carpenter ants specifically are there
any current recommendations that you
would have number one and then talking
about conventional or contrary to
conventional wisdom I think at this
point people are wondering how did this
guy become so obsessed with this stuff
so I do want to roll back the clock and
talk about among other things your
stutter but first I have to know is
there anything you would recommend as it
relates to carpenter ants or is it a
waiting game well the test of a patent
is that it's reproducible
the EPA and the USDA now are allowing
this fungus in food handling facilities
the first fungus ever to be allowed for
controlling insects in food handling
facilities it is that safe the safety
the safety documents supplied supplied
by the EPA are now open sourced and in
public domain so the companies that did
all the research proving that this
fungus was not dangerous
now I released all the commercial
interest in it this train of meta regime
called F 52 is that public domain strain
so what I'm saying is you're not legal
for you to go out and use this and
commercialize it without EPA
registration but that Tesla patent is
reproducible and so all of the methods
for doing this is published and and I'm
I just submitted my entire portfolio
with all my research you know all eight
or nine patents all the documentation of
all these companies that have done the
research you know in themselves and I've
submitted to a very very well-known
company that has an extremely potent
insecticide that many people know that
use it on the market and as the word I
got back is why would we want to disrupt
a proven profit wheel is something that
we've my aunts did not reinvade for 10
years because after the ants were killed
the carpenter ants they spoil Aidid so
this for repellency property prevented
future invasions that's not a very good
economic model when you can treat a
house once and they don't come back a
far better economic business plan is
having consumer buying it every month
and spraying toxic chemicals that kill
the workers but don't kill the Queen the
whole key to this is the mycelium is
taken back into the nest like a Trojan
horse it's presented to the Queen who
thence presents that our brood and
they're all living in this honey this
sort of my ciliated palace and then
before they realize it
it's sporty lights and that kills the
queen didn't kill the Queen it can
control colder colony after a spoilage
the spore repellency property prevents
other were carpenter ants from coming
into your house so it's a ten year
solution for about twenty five cents
that's what it costs to produce of
course the packaging and all that stuff
you add up the numbers pretty quickly
but it's incredibly it's very
inexpensive to produce and it can be
produced in huge quantities so it did
not make it to market and I'm
exasperated I'm one really great story
on this that this woman named Chris that
works for a company that has three
letters in their name he was she was
given the mandate because of the their
stockholders were really upset because
the reputation of this company causing
toxic spills that harmed thousands of
people and they wanted so they would
grow green movement can you find green
solutions she was given the mandate to
find a green solution to replace toxic
and sexercise she's given a budget if
she found me we dialogue for months I
gave her samples she set up experiments
to the researcher was so excited they
called me up at home and both of them
said I'm not supposed to be telling you
this but this is the most exciting thing
we've ever seen in our life you know as
as entomologist and fighting these
problems she went to the board of
directors prior the prior to going we
connected went over the data together
messaging you know how to create you
know the most clear communication to the
board of directors all men and she was a
steal in ignore Magnolia I've never met
her in person I wanted to hire her
immediately
she ran these these these meetings just
so professionally and she was really
excited and she went goes in the next
day in the afternoon I'm waiting for her
call and she calls and the person on the
phone is so angry I'm going who is this
and I go this is Chris she goes I'm so
angry I can't see straight I go I mean
she's totally composed before and she's
lost her composure I go Chris what
happened she goes I went in there I made
my presentation all men had looked at me
steely eyed and she said this is the
he gave me this mandate I found
something there's a game-changer they
can again we can come with a
ecologically rational and sustainable
solution based on nature and they looked
at her dour face and then the chairman
of the company looked at her and said
Chris your budget never was in research
it was an advertising very much similar
to B P remember beyond petroleum how
much of the VP's budget actually is an
alternative fuels versus how much is in
oil now how much of their advertising
budget is in alternative fuels as
opposed
so oil I mean clearly it's called green
washing and and so so that that was in
that just so that that happened like
seven or eight years ago and then this
past month I just had the same thing
happen again it's a disruptive
technology it rocks the apple cart and
many of these insecticides are coming
from the petroleum industry as
byproducts from their waste material so
I want to talk disruptive and something
challenging to the status quo and and
contrary to most conventional wisdom but
that requires going way way back and
talking a bit about perhaps your
childhood which you described in part
already but when did you develop a
stutter and why don't you still have a
stutter
I started stuttering when really when I
was about five years old I mean I
started from the time that I could talk
my family was this fun dysfunctional and
I've been told that sometimes the type
of stuttering that I have is it is
related to a defect a neurological
development in the seventh and eighth
month that's one possible reason but the
type of stutter and I have anyone seen
The King's Speech I had that and worse
so I could you know just could not speak
and I'd find alternative pathways to
trick my brain with a preposition or
adverbial phrase
because your brain gets further ahead
than your mouth can articulate and then
you become self-conscious and the type
of stutterer that I am as most others we
don't stutter when we sing we don't
stutter if I stop speaking in a British
accent or you create an accent and you
don't stutter when you talk to animals
so it's a very interesting it's a
something that's triggered by social
contact and so it was very difficult for
me to date ladies they wanted this super
Jaques the self-assured men and I was a
stutterer
decides to always stare at the ground
and I found fossils I found mushrooms
but it's very difficult for me now I
grew up in the small town in Ohio and my
dad was a officer on the aircraft
carrier the intrepid in Seoul during
World War two so after World War two he
got the intrepid aircraft carrier radio
and was in our basement so my brother
John he was very interested in chemistry
he created this huge you know huge like
three racks of chemicals you know in the
basement and his laboratory he had
Bunsen burners all sorts of experiments
going all the time and but he never let
me quote unquote play in the laboratory
I could play on the radio and I could
watch him but he's my older brother as
he missed one of my family so and so
John went on to Yale my brother Bill on
to Cornell and they left and had left me
this laboratory so my dream was always
to have a laboratory you know and living
in the country and that's kind of what
I'm doing now but John when he came back
from Yale he came back with a book
called altered states of consciousness
by Charles Hart and it was an anthology
of research articles on changing your
consciousness of them either drugs or
from spinning or from dreams you did one
of the early books from years of
california-davis so John let me this
book and I said Johnny I'd like to see
it but he says it well as I'm on break
for two weeks but I need the book
because part of our class so I got this
book I'm just devouring this book you
know and and John was my hero
he was my mentor
John went to Mexico and Colombia came
back with incredible stories of magic
mushrooms and consuming them you know I
just I adored him and of course I wanted
to do the same then he gave me this book
and so I'm really getting excited about
this but my best friend Ryan Schneider
wanted also to read this book and so
Ryan goes can borrow your book now your
brother's book and I go sure you can
borrow it but I need it back yes I was
give it back to me in two or three days
so several days pass and ask Ryan about
the book and he Hamden hard and a week
later where's the book and he wouldn't
respond sort of looking me in the eye
always a good sign yeah so I go where's
my book remember Blair's booking though
then two weeks at mileage on not
pressuring me Paul I need that text book
you know it's part of the class so I
finally got a hold of Ryan I said where
is my brother's book and my Ryan said
all I can't give it back to you I said
why so my dad found it and burned it I
said your dad burned my brother's book
what because yeah it was considered to
be the counterculture and threatening
you know to our family you know
structure or not I thought I could not
believe it though I was so upset and I
was so apologized to my brother who did
not take it well you know like last I'm
gonna trust you tell them they see you
so I was really bad and so so but I
thought to myself you know if this was
so disturbing to this alpha male you
know conservative you know neocon like
personality then I think I found the
subject I'm going to explore more so
that got me into magic mushrooms and
from my experience and also tremendous
amount of guilt for my brother trusted
me with this text book and I couldn't
return it to him so John was really
interested in the subject he inspired me
and then John went on the chemistry the
neurophysiology universe of Washington
Medical School on full scholarship and I
was left in the laboratory and so I
started experimenting with you know
marijuana
I remember the DEA came to Columbia
ohayo that they had a whole display of
drugs and a whole bunch of me and my
friend just went there to look at him
wow look at that way how old were you at
the time Oh 14 15 years of age I mean
drugs on display drugs you've heard
about you've never seen small that LLC
is that's incredible
so I still had this really bad
stuttering habit and it was really
socially debilitating on multiple levels
and so I ended up you know I was in Ohio
and I ended up buying a bag of magic
mushrooms and I've never was not really
into the drug scene so I don't know how
things should cost you know so I put 20
bucks up on a bag and I just a new
sentence setting was really important
but I had no guide nobody else in my
little circle was into it and so there
was a really great walk that I would
like to walk in the woods up on the
hills and beautiful rolling hills of
Ohio northern Ohio and and I thought
okay sentence I think is important so I
took the bag and and I thought that
would be one dose one those folks I
probably ate about 20 grams oh my god
Osby cubensis now in in defense of this
I need to make it clear these were not
grown these were harvested and so they
were exposed to the Sun so they may have
been only the equivalent to like ten
grounds so cubensis for people who are
listening five grams it's long to be
convinced this is the hero's journey you
know you're a full-blown you're into
starscape you're you know changing
dimensions your fractal patterns the
error becomes a sea of mathematical
formulas and your mind has opened up
your hearts opened up your feel one with
the universe that's that's a hero's
journey yes five grams you know you know
I don't get that until going over three
grams she started getting into it but so
10 to 20 grams is the superheros journey
I've never eaten these before so I
walked I was walking into this place
about an hour walk I started consuming
them and drinking water because they
were dried and then I saw a tree that I
loved climbing this tree had his limbs
so it was a perfect climbing tree and at
the very top of the hill so I thought
that's a great place I mean set in
setting or getting a good view that's
what I need I could feel the mushrooms
coming
and I as I climbed up the tree you know
stem branch by branch so I got higher
and higher so it was kind of a this
ascending euphoria you know they kind of
kind of went with everything it was very
cool and I got to the top of the tree
and beautiful landscape and I'm up there
and just the mushrooms are coming on and
getting higher and higher and and I just
realized I'm really getting high here in
a little it's a dizzying so I'm holding
on to the tree and on the horizon this
being black bank of boiling dark angry
clouds it was a summer storm coming in
in Ohio when you see the summer storms
or they're terrifying
they're lightning bolts coming down and
thunder and lightning there's off in the
distance but it's coming at me really
quickly and I'm getting higher and
higher as a thunderstorm lightning
storms coming closer and closer I'm
getting vertigo and I go oh my god I you
know I can't get off the tree I don't
want to fall so I held on the tree for
dear life and it became my axis mundi
sort of my axis right into the earth and
I just an amazing experience I mean just
beautiful experience but also the threat
of lightning coming closer and closer
and every lightning strike it would hit
and because you fractal patterns would
just emanate howl from every lightning
strike and the synesthesia occurred you
know where they're you know sound and
and and envisions were merging together
and and sounds had visions and visions
had sounds and it was just an incredibly
complex you know my my favorite books is
the glass bead game by by Hermann Hesse
ah I was also called Magister Ludi and
some other area died he got the Nobel
Prize for it in 1955 but that that was a
deep dive into into inner space
exploration but I felt like I was part
of the glass bead game and there I was I
was ascending into this higher state of
consciousness and I realized oh my god
I'm in the highest point in miles during
a lightning storm this is not a good
place to be and and then I was up there
I was terrified and a lightning storm
came closer and closer and I had these
pathogenic you know just empathy for the
universe
everything is fine if I die here today
my life is complete now I understand I'm
part of the fabric of all the matter
that surround me I'm one with everything
I'm made of Stardust everything's made
of Stardust this is a continuum of
nature death is natural birth as natural
transitions or are just the way of way
of existence and then the lightning
storm and the wind came up and washed
with with warm rain and it was just
terrifying a lightning storm and I I'm
up there and I'm thinking oh I'm gonna
die but if I don't die Paul what are you
gonna learn from this experience
challenge yourself right now this is all
great and wonderful but let's get down
to brass tacks what's your biggest
issues you're not gonna die what's your
biggest issue in life i stuttering I'm
having this dialogue with myself
I just can't overcome this stuttering
habit you know I'm not stupid and I went
to for people to understand how bad it
was I was interviewed for special
education because of my stuttering
because I couldn't read in class and so
when it's my turn to read I they would
pass on me because no one had the
patience to hear her stutter and please
don't finish the stutter resentence look
at them smile and engage help them
finish their sentence don't finish it
for them that robs them of the
opportunity of overcoming this speech
deficit so I scored high in my test so I
didn't get it put in a special education
but it was a pretty demoralizing to
realize I'm gonna go in to the special
education class but I didn't so I
thought stuttering was my issue and so I
started saying to myself Paul stop
stuttering now you can do this you're
not stupid he did come from a very smart
family you have you know you can do this
and so I said stop stuttering now over
and over and over again hundreds if not
thousands of times and the storm washed
over me I felt like I'd achieved a state
of Godhead I felt enlightened I come
from a Christian background so I had
this empathic empathy with Jesus you
know and now I understand why
Jesus went into wilderness now I
understand why Jesus you know said don't
go into churches go into nature whatever
you know that's my cultural background
but I saw I connected on that level and
I realized oh my gosh this is something
I can overcome so I came out of the tree
obviously did not get electrocuted and I
went back home and then the next morning
there's this girl that greatly admired
and she was super sweet and nice to me
and I really loved her to this day
because of her kindness and and I didn't
want to talk to her because every time I
I you know then you get these half
breaths going on and then you can't get
out of this loop and she's coming along
the sidewalk and the morning and she
looks at me and she's so sweet it's a
good morning Paul how are you
and I cast my eyes up from the sidewalk
and I looked at her and I said I'm doing
fine thank you for asking
and I stopped stuttering just like that
now I do have I've had about four or
five relapses you know if it's a lot of
noise and I've been drinking and
somebody asked me how do you grow
mushrooms it's like filling a well a
teaspoon like where do I begin
you know like so or if I'm eating some
of these super famous or something like
that you know it's but that's natural
you know people get stage fright on then
they're you know so but it's it's
something that I think is really
important because there's one other
aspect that related to hearing that I
want to mention and I have a really good
friend he's passed on now named Bill
Webb he's lived in Big Sur California
and I was 19 years old when I wrote my
first book selasa be mushrooms and their
allies I was self trained I got involved
University of Washington with dr. Daniel
stunts part of a taxonomic key Council
and I adopted the taxonomy of psilocybin
mushrooms as my speciality at that time
there was very little literature on it
most of the books and libraries had been
razored the pages have been raised about
doctor students had a intact library so
I could study with them I became a taxon
amidst
I wrote talks on McKee's starting was in
nineteen or twenty and that became the
core of my book so I'm I have this
manuscript and I go to Montana books in
Seattle to pitch the book and the
Montana books has breezing some some
gay-friendly literature and they were on
the cutting edge and I was recommended
that I see them and so I made an
appointment I go up to Seattle and I'm
meeting the head of Montana books hey
guys you know this is not our market
there's a you know interesting subject
really what you need is a book agent
because the best book agent I know is
Bill Webb and I haven't seen him in two
years and at the sounds of those words a
little Bell jingles on the front door of
Montana books and in walks bill Webb and
the publisher fun no way so bill and I
became tight friends he invited me down
to Big Sur he was a friend of Henry
Miller and and was just a really
fantastic individual he became a father
figure to me at a really critical time
in my life and so bill and I did
journeys together there are sacred
journeys with a ELA by obi-wan Kenobi
you realize I'm you know 19 20 years old
of age I'm with a 75 year old you know
who who's a friend of Ansel Adams he had
Ansel Adams library of many of his
imprints and working with his wife and
curating them I mean really cultured
intellectually interesting guy beautiful
place and so bill and I tripped several
times and it was a wonderful experience
for me yeah brings tears to my eyes just
talking about Bill and so bill he died
about 15 years ago and bill calls me up
about three or four months before he
dies and he goes Paul I have to tell you
something that's so important I'm bill
so I haven't heard from you in years
how's it going goes well frankly life
sucks I've lost losing my sight I'm
losing my hearing I can't hear the waves
so this equals now I live above the
cliffs of Big Sur except for this damn
hearing aid which is always
malfunctioning okay I hate it but I've
got to tell you something that's so
important that you
I know okay bill and I said what is it
and bill goes no we want you to listen
Paul this is important I'll go bill I
understand and then I kept on
emphasizing and so finally I got
frustrated bill I got the message okay I
know what you're gonna tell me is
important because I want to make sure
that you tell other people will you
promise me and I go I promise you he
said Paul I think I found something
medically very important about Saul
Simon I go what I said why don't were on
the hero's journey I was you know took
out my hearing aid I'm lying you know in
full bliss and one with the universe you
know he's like 80 years aged or 82 years
of age when he's doing this by himself
yes I know I can hear the seagulls I can
hear the waves oh my gosh I can hear
everything and then weeks for his
hearing aid he didn't have it in and
goes oh my gosh I can hear and then he
heard this click click click click tap
tap tap tap tap he looked around going
that's that's weird doesn't unusual
sound and click click click click tap
tap tap tap tap click click and he goes
he couldn't figure out what it was he
looked around he looked around and
finally he saw what it was there are
ants walking on the deck and he was
hearing their footsteps that is wild now
this is where even I and I'm a liberal
kind of guy I'm like wait a second
you know tell me that again you know and
that's why bill set me up by saying you
have to tell other people this so I've
been working with you with Roland
Griffiths at Johns Hopkins University
the clinical studies in Seoul Simon etc
and I really emphasize this to the many
of the researchers they could easily do
a test you know why these patients are
in session to test their hearing to see
if they have increased sensitivity
increased range tonal ranges is a very
easy metric but I think what happened
with me on the tree and the lightning
storm is that I created a new
neurological pathway of articulating my
thoughts and overcoming the social
phobia the social phobia is a trigger
it's definitely an environmental trigger
and then we get locked into these loops
there are really really strange another
good thing to tell a stutter room is can
you demonstrate different ways of
stuttering they'll do it you want me to
start different ways of stuttering I'll
give you three different ways of
stuttering and it's oh it's really weird
does that act as a pattern interrupt
that helps them to overcome at least
temporarily the stuttering or is it just
useful for a non stutter it or hear
different ways of stuttering hmm that's
I'm not sure how to answer that but I do
think that once that new neurological
pathways are systolic
you can capitalize on them by
remembering them this is a thing that
John Hopkins University some of the most
surprising results is 14 months after
these experiences when many of the
patients said there was a mostly
important spiritual experience of their
lives 14 months afterwards not only they
have demonstratable benefits being nicer
people being a better parent better
husband socially more well adapted but
the fact that they re remembered the
experience reinforced those benefits
that they experienced directly after the
experience so a lot of people people
listening may not understand these are
not my drugs of abuse you eat these
mushrooms one day the next day you no
way you look at them you got the
repellency property right the psilocybin
repellency property like I'm not talking
those four months but boy that was a
great experience you know so these are
not substances of abuse but they're
shockingly powerful to the point that
you're not ready for the humorous
journey for a long time so these are not
drugs of abuse by any stretch of the
imagination
they really should be recategorize as a
therapeutic drug definitely and this
this in many ways relates to your well
it relates to a few of your previous
stories very well in so much as a
psilocybin is very challenging as a
medical model in
in several respects one of which is that
it does not require say daily or weekly
administration and it is economically
difficult to create a for-profit model
unless you are monetizing the therapy
and adjunct pre and post support and
things of that type but not in the the
sort of one and done or three times and
done aspect of it actually makes it very
challenging to commercialize and make
widespread unless you're relating on or
relying on donations excuse me I would
love to hear your thoughts just to
expand on this a little bit do you think
say psilocybin or another that I know
very little about but wants to discuss
with you but I can talk about both or
either say lion's mane are there in this
case should I say mushrooms or should I
say mycelium or my cilia what would be
the right way to are it will be the
right term to use here well yeah
absolutely
mushrooms mushrooms are what people know
but mycelium is it emerging as a
tremendously important reservoir of many
bioactive molecules that are superseded
the benefit of mushrooms 25 and whole
genome sequencing of reishi mushrooms in
the genus Ganoderma these the common
Ling Ling Qi Ling sure reishi men and
talking the ten thousand year mushroom
the mushroom of immortality these are
all common names out of Asia they're 25%
more genes are active and expressed into
mycelial form than it is in the food
body form the food body is a mushroom
form at the end of its lifecycle so much
of our research has found going
side-by-side comparisons of mushrooms
which are protein rich they're beta
glucan rich they've lots of
carbohydrates and polysaccharides there
are nutritionally dense but the mycelium
is is articulating constantly a bio
shield of defense and from exposure when
the mushrooms form good luck to any
bacterium it's gonna rot it it's gonna
is go to spoil eating four or five days
and then gives himself up anyhow
moreover I think that the sequence of
bacteria that rots mushrooms is
absolutely instrumentally and important
for the evolution of the ecosystem that
give rise to the trees that create the
debris fields that feed the mycelium so
these are deterministic micro biomes and
the micro biome the the fungal biome is
determining the micro biome because many
of these bacteria are adversarial some
of our commensal some are actually
mutualistic ly beneficial so the
mycelium is this articulation in this
network that because of epigenesis the
ability to respond to environmental
stimuli and upregulate and express new
gene expressions it is a fertile ground
for learning for being able to
articulate responses as new challenges
in the environment the mushroom fruit
body is at the end of a thing but you
know people are attracted to mushrooms
and they fear that typically nature that
which is ephemeral now we're around
trees and around dogs and animals and
plants for weeks months years so the
familiar a factor of constant exposure
day to day gives us some confidence and
oh that animals not going to attack me
or that plant is one that my answers
have been using and and we understand it
but mushrooms that come up and disappear
with four or five days some can feed you
some can kill you some can heal you some
can send you on our psychoactive journey
that which is so powerful but so
ephemeral is naturally to be afraid of
them so we have about 200 species of
mushrooms that are edible medicinal I
don't know the difference between edible
and medicinal anymore all edible
mushrooms have medicinal properties but
the mycelium expresses a lot more of
these compounds and with lion's mane
there's a group of Aaron a scenes now
the lion's mane mushroom is called her
ischium erinaceus super Latin binomial
Paul I don't interrupt but I start pause
for one second to plant a seed and we
can come back to it or spore and come
back to it later which is potential
applications to neurodegenerative
diseases like Alzheimer's or Parkinson's
but I don't interrupt us want to plant
that seed so that I don't forget it
myself so please continue so the air
nations are some of the strongest neural
growth factors ever discovered
by science ngf factors are called neuro
factors and they regenerate myelin on
the axons of nerves so that lion's mane
is perfectly legal it has a long history
of use multi thousands years history of
you look like I cast it looked like
pom-poms at cheerleader issues yes white
cascading crystals a descending teeth
and it's a beautifully beautiful
mushroom that tastes like shrimp or
Lobster when you add butter to it when
you cook it but the compounds that are
most neuro generative are in it from the
mycelium not from the mushrooms and so
the Aaron a scenes are from the mycelium
Harrison owns are another group of neuro
factors they're from the mushrooms but
the erina seems by far much more neuro
regenerative there's been several
clinical studies that have come out on
mild cognitive dysfunction out of Japan
and they are very promising as an se
it's the first smart mushroom well
sulfide much would they be the first
smart mushroom in my mind but but but
lion's mane mushrooms is one mushroom
that I take on daily basis my mother
takes it on a daily basis she's almost
93 years of age and a few days she's
smart as a whip she beat my two brothers
in Scrabble not too long ago which was a
lot of fun I went really I told my boys
mom beat you at Scrabble you know she
got lucky that was a clean win then my
brother was very defensive but but
nevertheless my my the lion's mane
mushrooms I think are extremely helpful
to faretta neuropathies and I think
stacking them with psilocybin is
something I'm really keen on is doing
micro dosing of psilocybin stacked with
lions made now lion's mane in and of
itself we know as neuro regenerative
properties is a big subject of research
when you go to PubMed or Google Scholar
alerts you know put it in lion's mane
and neuro regeneration or and ngf
factors and you'll you'll there's
several dozen peer-reviewed articles
extensively exploring the region
generation of Milan which is the
conductive sheath on the axons of nerves
and those who gets Alzheimer's for
instance have amyloid plaque formation
that interrupts and the erodes the
myelin sheath prevents neurotransmission
and so lion's mane mushrooms have been
demonstrated behaviorally in people with
cognitive tests but also through
dissection of mice prior to using lion's
mane they would inject these mice with a
polypeptide that induces amyloid plaque
formation it's a very very potent toxin
that's neuro the neurotoxic but mimics
that of the what happens the nervous
system of Alzheimer's patients because
amyloid plaque formation can be yeah
conform their behavior changes they lose
the ability of navigating through mazes
they lose the novelty acquisitiveness
factor factor the short term memory is
basically erased or much of it and then
when they've had them lion's mane
mushrooms when they dissected mice and
sure enough they saw that the amyloid
plaque formation was there and then
there's fully diseased mice when they
would then feed them lion's mane
mushrooms for 23 days they regain the
ability of navigating through maze they
really engaged inquisitive Ness it's
called the novelty response the novelty
experiment and upon dissecting those
knife and the resections of the tissue
they could see that the amyloid plaque
had largely resolved remyelination had
occurred and so here you bundle that
with you know you've got a behavior as
well as physical evidence of
regeneration of myelin
so lion's mane mushrooms are just a very
very fascinating mushroom I think about
Einstein and in his last days I think
about some of my mentors in my ecology
and their very last days we are losing
encyclopedic knowledge these are mental
giants that have so much to give to the
next generation as part of our national
heritage our intellectual national
heritage and to lose these these
geniuses with all this experience all
this knowledge all this sense of being
and context to lose them at
the end of their life is us losing a
library that just as the library books
that fall into pieces in your hands and
and I think it's so important for our
culture's to preserve that knowledge and
I think lion's mane mushroom is a huge
one the the slow descent into sort of
cognitive malfunction is is what I would
cite when people ask me what I'm afraid
of
I mean that that is it I mean being
trapped in your body without the
cognitive capabilities that you would
want or need to not just function but
thrive and I completely agree with you
this is something I've been fixated on
for quite some time if you were to if
you were to design a study involving the
micro dosing micro administration of
psilocybin under proper supervision and
you know sort of researcher controls
what might give any idea what that might
look like what the protocol might look
like it's a very timely question because
in two hours from now I have a group of
financial people that are key and
supporting the current Sullivan research
at Johns Hopkins and elsewhere they're
arriving here specifically and staying
with me for three days to talk about
exactly this I had an idea and I'm gonna
probably open-source this I sometimes I
file patents says I call them blocking
patents I file a patent I think should
be open-source in order so other people
can't get a patent on and this might be
in that category it's this whole patent
landscape I'm I'm I see both sides of
the arguments of open sourcing and then
also keeping things close source but I
found a patent on neurogenesis you can
look it up stacking lion's mane
psilocybin and myosin nicotinic acid now
I spoke before what is patentable it is
no prior art it speaks against
conventional wisdom so and when I gave a
talk at maps recently I asked the
audience about 800 people how many
people remember during the 1970s and 80s
it was well known especially on the west
coast if you want to come down from a
bad trip on psilocybin or LSD you could
take a bunch of niacin you'll get a hot
flood a flush and people who don't know
I'm going to take like 500 milligrams of
niacin you get red and you get tingly
all over your skin you've got this
niacin flush and about 50 people raised
their hand I actually recorded that I
needed that for my patentability because
that was common knowledge that niacin
counter after the effects of psilocybin
I think not number one there's no
evidence that that's true but it was
common knowledge number two because the
excites the nerve endings and neuropathy
is oftentimes occur than the deadening
of the nerves at the fingertips and the
toes it struck me that if I could excite
the nerve endings
perhaps I could drive these lion mane
and lion's mane RNA scenes and the soul
siphon to the endpoints of the nervous
systems
if the vascular system still intact to
deliver these compounds to create
neurogenesis and prevent a neuropathy at
the endpoints of the nervous system so I
filed a patent stacking niacin
psilocybin and lion's mane the
psilocybin dosage is about one-twentieth
of a gram now that is below the
threshold of what people would
experience any change in consciousness
so I know lots of people who would not
dare take us also mushroom the idea of
taking 120th below threshold dose that
way to create neurogenesis and braaap
make them cognitively more astute and
make them a better person
you know socially and intellectually I
know a lot of people are interested in
that and plus it's kind of groovy it's
kind of sexy yeah older people have
favored their kids yeah I'm microdose
saying you know my goodness thing is
extremely popular right now as you
probably are well aware but that's
something that we would like to see a
clinical study now the clinicals that we
already know for the new clinicians out
there you have too many variables in
your in your clinical study and I agree
so we were looking at psilocybin alone
this Lions made alone so Simon stack
with with lion's mane the niacin will
have to come later because it's just you
and you need
of cohorts and not people enrolled in
the clinical study in order to have a
statistical significance almost uttered
there so that's that that's what we're
looking at is looking at stocking this
and and we maybe do this clinical study
in Canada right now the FDA is very
favorable to these clinical studies I
had a report from somebody met with the
FDA regulators and their scientists and
they said they have never seen a drug
that was so non-toxic so effective from
one treatment in the history of they're
looking at approving new drugs and they
were like so the FDA scientists are
quite focused on this it's something we
all you know the difference between a
medicine and a toxin is dose
I wouldn't call psilocybin a toxin well
there's maybe one funny example that
just came out in the literature of that
but um I wouldn't call it this Larry
auxin but having a sub threshold dose I
think makes a is it it's a really valid
approach because and you probably
shouldn't take these every day because
you'd normalize the receptors you know
and so Washington receptors and having
them recalibrate themselves is probably
a good thing to do so
pulse therapy three to four days on
three to four days off is um probably a
better approach than taking them every
day mm-hmm so the jury's out on that I'm
a lot of different opinions but of it's
um it's it's endlessly fascinating
though and you are right on them on the
money so to speak or lack of money given
how effective they are in limited number
of sessions at the combination which is
certainly has been studied and is being
studied of efficacy and low toxicity and
as you mentioned earlier if a rat if you
put and you know Michael Pollan and I've
chatted about this a little bit in his
podcast but if you were to administer
say
to a rat and a box cocaine or heroin and
they have to choose between those drugs
or food they will consume these types of
opiates or stimulants until they die it
to the absence of food whereas with say
LSD I would also assume psilocybin they
they take one dose and that's the last
time they touched that particular and
this is uh I don't want to take us too
far afield and focus on this exclusively
but I really appreciate you having spent
so much time thinking about how these
natural companions who have coexisted
and have been ingested by humans for
thousands of years can be applied for
some of these it's epidemic scale
problems that we're experiencing and I
wanted to ask we are going to talk about
some of the applications of mushrooms
outside of human medicine but I would
love to read a description of you and
then it releases something we were
chatting about a little bit before we
started recording and talk about the the
decisions that made Paul Stamets Paul
Stamets because there are so many
mycologists out there and I certainly
don't know the exact number but you are
if not the best-known certainly one of
the best-known and the description is
from Mother Jones says Paul Stamets is a
modern example of the amateur scientist
from the 17th and 18th century who made
a wonderful who made wonderful
contributions with only their native
curiosity and keen sense of observation
and you can certainly comment on that if
you don't feel like it's accurate but
what what are the decisions you made if
any come to mind or habits you've
cultivated that have allowed you helped
you to arrive where you are I mean you
have made many discoveries you've you've
excelled in multiple fields why is that
how did you become who you are in this
current moment and you can start
anywhere I'd want to be one of the
people who asks you had you crow
mushrooms
at a cocktail party I have been exposed
to a circle of kindness and I believe in
karma I was a child who had a lot of
problems and I want a big debt of
gratitude to my professor dr. Michael
Boog
he never humiliated me you know at the
Evergreen State College I make some dumb
statements he was entertained by them
but entertaining
by them in a humorous way that engaged
me to explore you know you know and dive
more deeply into the subject matter but
I was never humiliated and as a circle
of kindness and I really believe in
karma because this has meant this has
been a huge thing in my life is the fact
that I believe evolution is an extension
of gratitude and sharing and it's not
this necessarily this this neo-darwinian
concept of competition the first the
food wins it's a collaboration of people
who are elide together of a common
interests and we needed Shepherd all of
our ourselves from our weaknesses to
become stronger what very few lots of
people know this but very few different
schools that people know this I got into
the martial arts when I was 14 I have
two black belts
I had schools for 30 40 years
I have long haired hippy was a nice
person and I kind of turned into a
different individual I've been in
thousands of fights I started to a spin
the character martial arts I first got
in to go to Russia Shotokan XI Tohru got
my first black belt in Taekwondo and
then began I'm black on Guangzhou which
is by far one was sophisticated styles
in the world
similar to Hapkido and and some other
styles Kuk Sool but that I had one
experience that I think is emblematic of
this is I was an early young black belt
in Taekwondo and a big biker came in he
was just seething with anger and wired
onset amines and and and he wants to
fight a black belt you know just a biker
dude and just pissed off at the world
and he came in and and number the head
instructor does not quite a challenge
like this they have too much to lose
you know if they screw up you know lose
spaceman from their students so you know
many of my my head instructor Jeanne
said oh I got another one okay and so
this Michael came in and then inside let
you fight one of my black belts this is
fine so Paul come over here and so I
came over there and it's really polite
and you know I said in my hand shook my
hand he wouldn't shake my hand he just
was all piss and vinegar and wanted to
fight me and I said well we have a few
rules take off your shoes you know and
and then we got out on the mat and this
guy just attacked me for Rochas Lee I
mean it was no no sort of like the
boxers you know they have a little bit
of like okay let's do it you know we
have a little compassion for each other
you know the little simpatico or another
fellow warrior now this guy was like out
there hurt me as I block block block
block block this guy's just you're just
swinging and kicking in the key can't
kick well number one but he's just like
overly aggressive and and you know after
a while you know you can block ten or
twenty times but you know you started
getting hurt right you know the these
are these guys just promotionally trying
to hurt me and so I looked over at the
my head instructor and he nodded his
head and said okay Paul time to take him
out you know
the three or four punches you know
sucker-punched him did a jumping hook
kick BAM hit him in the temple BAM that
he went down on the ground
you know semi-conscious and then I'm
hovering over and I put my hand onto his
trachea I put my middle finger into the
inside of his eyeball and that way I
could pop his eyeball I'm pulling his
trachea at the same time now what people
are really concerned about their vision
and also in their face you know so when
you Glock your finger into the eyeball
and ready to take out the eyeball people
want to give up really fast he was
terrified he had the look of like oh my
god I'm gonna lose my eyeball and this
guy's got you know even he was just
waking up from being stunned from his
kick you know I got him like that
and I knew I had it okay this is it now
I can take him out right now this is the
end of his life you know and it was you
know basically it's done and then I go I
released I said you know you actually
did really well I extended my hand and
friendship he's laying on the mat this
big burly biker guy started crying
cuz I was nice to him I took him down
but I wasn't glorifying in my win I was
extending my hand in friendship changed
his life when I left the school he was a
brown belt he became this big teddy bear
he's shepherding all these little I told
missing the girl here she's got a yellow
belt you've got a white belt you bow to
her that's the way it works here just
based on your experience and respect
totally changes life so so that's a
story of my life is that you know the
extension of and I think psilocybin
mushrooms make people nice for people I
just really believe that there is this
understanding that your life is not just
your life your life is in the context of
nature and how are we going to inspire
and lead and promote the forces of good
and generosity and mutualism and how
we're going to get away from the people
who want to tear it all down everybody
might work with bees I think is is the
is the cost 11 of my life and and we're
definitely gonna dig into that I want to
explore it I was just gonna echo what
you said about the power of kindness a
friend of mine very good friend of mine
was just telling me recently who perhaps
not surprisingly has a lot of psychotic
experience its mileage with certain
mushrooms that we've been discussing and
also for anyone who doesn't know what
map says it's the multidisciplinary
Association of psychedelic studies
they're also focused very heavily on
Phase three trials for MDMA in the
treatment of PTSD which is is
fascinating and I encourage people to
take a look at that at maps org but what
my friend said to me is not too long ago
several weeks ago he went into a coffee
shop and it was some dunkin donuts or
something like that an airport and this
woman said thank you at the end of the
transaction and he looked at her in the
eyes and he said no thank you and he was
just kind of being a joker and he's a
charming guy but he meant it very
sincerely and she just
down crying similar experience like she
had not had it didn't seem anyone
express kindness to her and God knows
how long
I mean weeks months who knows and it
just was such a stark reminder just like
your story about the power of those
little acts those tiny little micro
decisions that we all make thousands of
times a day and that's what you know I
have a business
well you know I'm but anybody was
ordered from our business I owned the
business so I run it and I had several
years ago I got these little stickers
they say you are beautiful hmm and every
time someone orders from our business
and their order are - you are beautiful
stickers and I've had so many people
write saying they were just horrible day
a physician or just wrote to me recently
he ad said oh my god I cannot believe
this little messaging I send too because
then they can pass one forward so every
order and every box there are - you are
beautiful stickers and so many people
have written saying that's what they
needed to see that changed their entire
day that again extension of gratitude
and affirmation you know and we are all
on this planet together we lifted live
in this time and space Tim you're gonna
die I'm gonna die everybody listening to
this podcast is gonna die but we really
enter into the fabric of nature from
which we sprung and I think that fabric
in nature is based on the extension of
goodness I just know it empirically and
all the noise we have around politics
and everything else is just so narrowly
focused in the context of the greater
being I think that we are on the verge
where science and spirituality are
converging and now we're understanding
nature and the extent of the cosmos the
hundreds of billions of galaxies I mean
just um I always wanted to be an
astrobiologist I kind of am now in some
sense but I've always wanted and I think
we'll find fungal networks throughout
nature throughout the universe on
multiple planets multicellular organisms
will form as networks networks will give
rise to animals and I think that the we
are descendant of this network-based
paradigm that's represented not only in
mycelium and the neurons the computer
internet the organization of dark matter
this is a continuing continuation on
different orders of magnitude of the way
of being we are in all involved in this
network of being and this is just one of
our strands in that network that we're
living today and I want to get to bees
and I'm gonna get to it by way of laying
out some illustrations of these these
webs these strands of interconnectedness
and this is from Discover Magazine from
a few years back and I'm just going to
quote here it'll take 30 to 60 seconds
probably and then I want to talk about
bees specifically it starts with this
and this is a very incomplete list of
course but stamens is researching a wide
variety of ways in which fungi could
help solve human problems here is a
partial list one environmental cleanup
mushrooms could be used to break down
petrochemicals or observe radiation from
contaminated soil and water to waste
water filtration mushroom mycelium could
cleanse runoff from storm drains farms
or log logging roads they can be used to
filter out the nitrates endocrine
disruptors and pharmaceutical residues
that disrupt ecosystems and damage human
health three pesticides fungal bug
killers which we discuss could be used
to target troublesome species while
remaining non-toxic to other four
medicines which we've discussed could
provide new antibiotic antiviral and
immune boosting compounds and even chemo
therapies five forestry planting
symbiotic mushroom species could speed
reforestation and clear-cut woodlands
six agriculture adding oh this is the
word that I can never pronounce adding
my co r r h IC al how do how do we say
that mycorrhizal mycorrhizal thank you
adding mycorrhizae fungi to soil could
improve crop yields without the need for
toxic chemical fertilizers seven famine
relief mushrooms could be grown rapidly
in refugee camps and disaster zones
using just wood chips or salt water
soaked straw eight biofuels growing
mushrooms for biodiesel could require
far less soil and other resources than
commonly cultivated fuel crops 9 which
segues to what we were just chatting
about space travel because of their
usefulness in soil creation and the
tolerance of many speeds
for radiation mushrooms could be grown
by interstellar voyagers and used to
terraform other worlds so I'm gonna
pause here for one second just to let
people soak in that and then second in
both preparation for this conversation
but also over the last two years reading
various descriptions of what has been
called the the Wood Wide Web I think is
what they call it he into the mycelium
and how they facilitate communication
between trees and other organisms it's
really mind-bending stuff I mean it's
it's it's the type of narrative and
description and discovery that if
described I'm just making this up
perhaps but like 50 years ago it would
have been thought science fiction and I
would love for you to describe what you
have done in the world of bees but I
just find this so not only staggeringly
fascinating and much of it
counterintuitive but important so that's
my that's my soapbox for the moment but
in any case would would love you to take
that wherever you'd like okay well I
would recommend that people read my book
mycelium running how mushrooms can help
save the world
it covers into these subjects very very
deeply and then the book is used now as
a introductory mycology book at many
universities I typically don't promote a
product from stage there's no lecturers
out there you can find this but I do
want to draw people's attention to fungi
calm fu ng I calm there's an amazing
letter from a Syrian refugee and I want
people we obscured his face because we
don't want him to be targeted by Assad
Assad SAS ins but he has brought in
mushroom cultivation and in refugee
camps using recyclable materials from
the cardboard and all the paper and he
literally you have to read the letter to
it just brings tears to your eyes he's
over a thousand people now engaged in
growing mushrooms oyster mushrooms and
refugee camps and then from the Syrian
crisis that are helping people feed
themselves and and think about all those
thousand people now understanding how to
grow mushrooms what the downstream
effect will be with their children when
they get out of this can
still have skill sets that can really
expand this and in a huge way
I believe that my psyllium is the
foundation of the food web it is
essential for food biosecurity I
mentioned the mycelium creates the
michael by Holmes we've done next-gen
sequencing we've been able to prove this
i've not published it but people can see
my talks on it showing that different my
silly mycelial mats control and destined
populations of bacterias are uniquely
specific to the mycelium that is growing
in in wood chips or in straw
so they actually articulate the
populations and bacteria downstream from
the mice allele networks but this is
kind of segue so we talked about the the
antiviral stuff you know the bio shield
about defense program and 911 well and I
had this antelope pathogenic fungi
patents and working against you know
termites and carpenter ants and and
bedbugs and mites and so a good friend
of mine Louis Schwartzberg he actually
has finished a movie called fantastic
fungi is coming out the next few months
we've been making it for over ten years
with a linear a linear Norman Lear and
his that group and the the I just saw
the final cut a few days ago it is quite
good I'm really happy where where it's
going but it talks about the wood wide
web and Susan's Simard is a british
columbia mycologist and i'm a total fan
of her work and a big kudos to her
because she and I are two peas in the
pod she was doing her work parallel to
am I doing mine and and we ended up and
you know really in the in the same
intellectual ecosystem so to speak
but so when Louie was doing a movie he
was looking at
butterflies since then he got into bees
and colony collapse and Coney collapse
is really corn collapse disorder is a
euphemism created by the media but it
does speak to a very serious issue an
Oklahoma last year 74% of the bee hives
died
now think of it if you were having
cattle or sheep at your ranch and you
lost 75% of your sheep or cattle that is
devastating
what's also devastating to beekeepers 35
percent or more of our food is directly
dependent upon bee pollination 70
percent is indirect many people don't
realize that most of our dairy products
are depend upon bee pollination because
alfalfa and hay that depended upon bees
all the almonds that you consume every
one almond that you consume was visited
by a bee on that flower and so the
almond industry specifically needs
honeybees in particular and so Louie
came to me is appalled is that there's a
huge problem with colony collapse and
bees are dying what can you do about it
well I had a series of events and these
events when you string them together led
to minute to an epiphany and then I am a
controversial mycologist I have been
trained academically in my ecology as an
undergraduate student but I married a
woman levan years older than me who had
three kids 12 14 and 16 when I was 22 I
couldn't afford to move my kids to other
cities to go to graduate school I got
accepted into several graduate schools
but I couldn't afford to move so I
started this little mail-order business
impact 30,000 boxes before I had a
single employee now I have over 100
employees so it's a real testimonial to
stamina and good luck and also the
extension of generosity by some very
kind people who came to my rescue a few
times over my life but in the course of
looking at the situation with bees I
started looking at it in this there's
many cofactors now health or disease in
my mind is a series of coefficient
variables factors which are strung
together the end of the equation means
health or disease so there is not a
single cause for colony collapse it's a
perfect storm of unfortunately bad
things have been happening to the bees
habitat loss one neonicotinoids we
already know they've been banned in
Europe ironically from a study that
Berenson
sponsored thinking that neo Nix would
not be toxic and they found out they
were toxic and so they were banned in
Europe last month neo and X are still
used in the United States and Canada
these there's so many 70% of the food is
thought to be absolutely critically
dependent upon bee pollination services
you know two arm's length away from
directly pollination contact so bees are
dying because of a confluence of
variables lava habitat neo Nick's
pesticide exposure factory farming if
not natural for me to put on trucks and
travel a thousand miles to the almond
orchards of California they all are
concentrated they spread diseases
amongst themselves and then they
disperse and so that's a great great
scenario for disease to be spread but by
far the biggest one that's been
identified in scientific literature is
the varroa mite and the varroa mite was
introduced in 1987 it came from Asia
varroa destructor is Latin by known and
do I know the binomial it injects a
whole slew of viruses into the bees and
these are these now all bees in the
world have these viruses working with
the USDA dr. J Evans and it was a USDA
virologist who's widely published and a
senior scientist at the USDA has not
seen a virus free be more than ten years
what's happened now is a virus is being
spread by the varroa mite in the borough
of might was controlled by a miticide
that was used to control ticks on cattle
called a Madras now Amma tries is not
legal to use by beekeepers but they use
it they were soaking their beehives with
this Amma tries this toxic you know tick
miticide and they're drenching it twice
per year to control the mites and now
they're up to eight times per year
within ten years the mites have
developed a resistance the mites are
like having a pancake on your back they
attach themselves they're extremely hard
to dislodge and now 27 viruses have been
identified being vectored by mites
what's the big surprise is all the wild
bee
now have these viruses and 80% of the
pollination services that we benefit
from from bees pollinating are actually
coming from wild bees not the honeybee
which is apis mellifera which is a
breeze huge colonies that the wild bees
are oftentimes called solitary bees are
very small groups of a dozen bees or two
dozen bees or ground dwellers and those
bees provide over 80 percent of the
services that are benefiting agriculture
so the honeybees demand we have about
two million hives in the United States
the average loss right now is over 50
percent nationally a few hotspots where
there's hot spots then emanate out and
epidemics become pandemics and so now we
have evolved into a viral pandemic of
these viruses spreading throughout the
world and it was just discovered in the
past two years three years that these
bees are infected with these viruses
when they visit a flower and they get
the pollen on them they also spread the
viruses to the pollen they leave and so
when the wild bees come they become
infected so this is a direct threat to
worldwide food biosecurity the loss of
bees is such an important issue and
interestingly it's a number one bridge
issue between liberals and conservatives
so I like to tell people you all right
Thanksgiving dinner you don't want to
talk about Hillary or Trump talk about
the importance of bees there's a number
of one issue that brings liberals and
conservatives together because everyone
recognizes the importance of beasts as
it is that for food biosecurity so my
friend Louie came to me and I started
studying this subject and I had five
experiences in a row that led to me to
an epiphany and no matter what my
critics say and I you know I've been
wrong sometimes I'm not right all the
time so I accept that but I pushed the
envelope because I'm not too worried
about tenure I'm self-employed I can
risk to be wrong but the more I
speculate the more I test the more I do
research you know that's what it takes
it takes efforts to see if something
will work and so I've failed a lot of
times and the failure is the price of
tuition I paid to learn new lesson all
that being said this is what happened
in 1984 I had the garden giant mushroom
growing in my garden
it's a woodchip mushroom it wasn't
woodchips produces mushrooms up to five
pounds per specimen people can look it
up and I had these wood chips permeated
with mycelium and I had two beehives
then one day in July I come out and I
see the bees all over my woodchips I
look really closely they're moving the
wood chips to the side just like you
pushing a semi-truck throw aside some of
these which is really big to expose the
mycelium and I looked very carefully and
from dawn to dusk for 40 days there's a
continuous convoy of bees to the my wood
chips of a garden giant mycelium in my
garden traveling about eight hundred to
a thousand feet as I went out there I
photograph it thank God I found the
photographs there were Kodachrome cg4
slides and sweltering heat you know two
years ago I found them up in that attic
but I published this in Harris first
magazine 1988 I published this in 1994
and growing gourmet medicinal mushrooms
one of my books and I speculate oh the
bees are going after the sugar rich
exudates
because they my cell name is produced in
these polysaccharides they're sweet and
they're fragrant and maybe that's why
the bees are going there okay that's
that's one I'm gonna give you a micro
factorial equation so that's the first
micro factor factor number one Paul sees
bees attracted the woodchips
in this garden I forgot about it Michael
factor number two Paul gets involved the
Bioshield program discovers that
polypore mushrooms have antiviral
properties and many patents have issued
now I have more patents on this people
can look them up and so that was another
experience that I had number three even
by getting rid of carpenter ants in my
house using enta my path of genetic
fungus realizing that insects are
vectors of disease and then moving
forward I'm looking at the research
articles and in PLoS it's an open source
you know online journal scientific
journal there's and the cover of the
plot was a big article on the discovery
that see
McCarney collapse happens most people
don't know this is that you go out to
your beehives on Monday everything is
fine you go out there on Thursday and
they're all gone they're gone
it's not like there's a whole bunch of
dead bees laying and from the Beehive
they're gone they fly away it turns out
that the bees are the deformed wing
virus which is the number one virus of
concern that's been identified by
researchers almost dozen papers have
been published in the past three years
identifying the daily born deformed wing
virus as the virus that is the most
debilitating to the bees it not only
reduced the total strength of their
wings but their deform they can't fly at
all we see bees on flower it's the last
days of their life these used to get
pollen for nine days and now they're
going out for four days so they can't
bring enough pollen back to the hive so
the newly hatched bees which are nurse
bees are prematurely recruited to go out
to get pollen because the colony is
stressed and then the brood has mites on
them and the bees can't attend to the
brood so they abandon the babies and
then mites then freely go around
injecting these viruses into the bees
and so at some point it comes to a
tipping point
and then the bees leave hive and they
don't come back so imagine if you were
again a cattle rancher or sheep rancher
you losing more than 50% of your is to
is psychologically damaging there's
always economically damaging and people
just give up so I had these experiences
and then I saw in this journal that they
looked at the honey and the abandoned
beehives it lacked a certain chemical
called peak who Merrick acid peak Americ
acid is the chemical trigger that
governs the detoxification pathway in
bees it's called the cytochrome p450
pathway all animals use it we haven't
mostly in our liver is how we break down
toxins without peak Americ acid they
found these bees hundreds of pounds of
honey no bees in a beehive
it lacks as essential nutrient peak
chimeric acid now I'm not a chemist but
I'd seen peak Americ acid before because
in the research I've done I look at
what's called the deal identification of
wood how fungi gobble up wood and break
it down and I recognize peak Americ acid
as a chemical constituent that was
present in breaking down wood that's why
you see my ciliated wood smells fragrant
no difference there's a lot of casting
of Michael flavonoids phenol phenolic
compounds that are going into and this
way after Iranian in the Oh in the woods
the woods feel smells so good that's the
outgassing of mycelium all these scent
trails are being created to entice us
and insects and other animals to follow
scent trails and part of the outcasting
of the mycelium okay I had all those
four experiences and then I go to sleep
and I have a waking dream that his
waking dream hit me like a lightning
bolt except oh my god I woke up I think
I saw I think I know how to save the
bees and so I first called it a very
good friend of mine least mine I said
this is a waking dream I just this it
shook me to the core he said stop
everything you're doing focus on this
this is too important so called the
universe of california-davis
it's never a good idea to start a
conversation with other scientists that
you've not met with the words I had a
dream that conversation went nowhere
it's like crazy person goodbye so I call
my boy State University I was at Ted I
think that the Ted that you were spoke
at and I was at Ted and I went out and I
was given Steve Shepards name from
Washington University he's a chair of
entomology in Pullman Washington
Washington University of agricultural
science college and I said listen Steve
please just give me a half an hour it's
gonna sound crazy to you at first but
let me talk to you about this about 15
minutes then he said stop go nowhere
else we want to work with you so the end
result of this is we tested this on 532
beehives in Southern California two
years ago we've done seven tests now and
outdoor beehives
we have found something I think this
extraordinary breakthrough with our
mycelial extracts of these polypore
mushrooms these these would conks that
look like the cold
with shape mushrooms that grow on trees
everyone's seen them with the mycelium
that's extracted and water and ethanol
the very same extracts that we use in
the bio bio defense program we gave it
to the bees and we've submitted an
article to a renowned scientific journal
and from one dose at 1% all beekeepers
feed sugar water to their bees this 50%
sugar if it wasn't water
so one milliliter per hundred you know
one unit 400 one percent we give it to
the bees and then seven to twelve days
later those viruses are reduced by
thousands of times in the article that
we submitted
we reduced the lake Sinai virus by more
than 45,000 times the deformed wing
virus more than eight hundred times with
one dose and it doubles the lifespan of
bees a think of the implications of this
this means that I think I have a window
now in understanding something
fundamental to the foundation of nature
the mycelium not only controls our micro
biomes and our deterministic in a
downstream evolution of ecosystems but
they also control the illogical health
of the animal inhabitants because the
very same extracts that reduce viruses
that harm birds bird flu h5n1 h3 h1n1 in
pigs that harm people poxviruses herpes
viruses birds pigs people bees this
speaks to something I think that is very
deeply profound an understanding that
within nature these mice alone and that
works are everywhere every tree is
infused with my psyllium every vegetable
you eat is infused with fungi this is a
part of the mutualistic relationship
that we have with these fungi they
increases the host defense and
resistance against disease there's a
plurality of fungi and such diverse
populations that create a matrix of
defense we have found that these
individual species now we tested five
different pollen
mushrooms they're all active to do
different degrees what we have not
reported in the scientific article that
we submitted is that we have one result
there's over a hundred million times
reduction of these viruses with one
treatment many of these viruses herpes
viruses have known as uncle viruses that
cause cancer lots of them cause
inflammation that destabilizes the
immune system this is something I think
is so critically important everyone's
talking about bad news and we are in the
sixth X the sixth great extinction
knowing the life on this planet we have
8.3 million species releases losing more
than 30 thousand a year
do the math 100 years that's more than a
third of the biodiversity as unraveling
all around us what can we do this is
actionable ecological solutions this
paradigm-shifting scalable ecologically
rational economically sustainable
again all these fungi grow in every
forest of the world and we all grew up
with Winnie the Pooh and everybody
missed this now I've been issued now 10
patents the United States Canada
Australia New Zealand in Eurasia when I
first got the first patent award for
five seconds I was excited literally and
then it became horribly demoralized I
said you've got to be kidding there's no
prior art no-one they did the patent
offices the most matter they have
massive search engines and every
language Chinese French Japanese English
German and there's not a single mention
anywhere out there that bees benefit
from my silly nummy neurologically and
what let alone reducing the viruses that
are being vectored by mites the fact
that I'm the one to discover this is
horribly depressing it means that we're
truly Neanderthals with nuclear weapons
and people talk about climate change and
now biodiversity is about the liberal
scientists are you freaking kidding this
is so fundamental to who we are and
where we've come from so I'll open
source that all the developing countries
with less but you know Europe and
Eurasia
not not Asia not South America not
Mexico not Africa you know in order for
a solution to be effective it's gotta be
practiced in order to be practices going
to be commercially unsuccessful in order
for it to be commercially successful
it's got to go to market with some
protection that of your idea but the
fact that that these patents are issuing
is a you know I'm I've made mistakes and
there's mycologist out there whose eyes
roll but I'm very happy to receive
several rewards one of which from the
microwave Society of America for
bringing more students in the field of
mycology than anyone in history so
they're kind of schizophrenic about me
because I'm a psychedelic researcher I'm
not trained by bringing all these
students into their classrooms I want to
save the world
they said Paul you fitted a pretty huge
problem we want to study yeast and these
students want to save the world what do
we do so um but so I think this is
something that is actionable solutions
and I think I can make the argument and
this is very provocative but I can make
the argument that natural products can
be more powerful than pharmaceuticals
with a greater bio shielded offense with
less toxicity and more utility in a
sustainable way and that I think is
paradigm-shifting I hope you're right I
hope you're right and I look forward to
learning more about this as the
discussion opens is there anything for
people listening who are not mycologists
nor future mycologists who want to help
in some fashion meaning they want to
make personal decisions maybe think of
policy changes or types of support that
would enable them to be part of an
environmental and systemic solution
rather than simply compounding the
existing problems are there new
behaviors things they can do anything
that you would suggest to people who are
listening absolutely the simplest thing
that people can do is let wood rot give
up this idea of as a be thin yard is
highly manicured and managed nature
likes fractal phases the factorization
of nature that
orders of magnitude it gives all these
niches to microorganisms and a
microbiome biodiversity that's critical
for sustainability
so rather than letting hauling the wood
off having a running a lot but let raw
logs rot and your in your garden in your
yard mushrooms will come up that will
help feed the bees
they'll help build these refractory
intense environments that are really
important for biodiversity that's one we
have a campaign for supporting
Washington State University debut at WSU
dot B B's dot WSU edu we've raised over
three million dollars and now for bee
research at WSU we have just begun to
explore the role of these polypore
mushrooms there's hundreds of them to
test we've hit the home runs on our very
first ones we're extremely lucky but the
fact that you know this is speaks we can
reduce these viruses forty five thousand
to one with one treatment I mean what
antiviral drug will do that you know
that is a complex soup of constituents
or you know the contrast is is
surprising so supporting B Company B
nonprofits joining a mushroom society
these the North America mycological
Association which is a parent
organization for called namma and their
website is named eco dough our ji na my
co dot o-r-g they have a listing of all
the local mycological societies you know
in people in the Canada United States
and Mexico
that's one joining your be get involved
in supporting frankly farmers and
developing bio diverse landscapes and
the March to monoculture and the march
to the industrialization of Agriculture
is sacrificing the very bio diverse
networks that have evolved to help
plants grow when you add lots of
fertilizers and insecticides you defeat
the natural systems of the mycelium that
has engaged
help plants for hundreds of millions of
years when you have mycelium helping
plants you do not need external inputs
as much as fertilizers etc and I think
there are ecologically rational
solutions to many of the problems that
we face today but it really speaks to
the concept of seven generations and
first peoples really have this so much
as a pillar of their understanding and
dealing with nature we should give up
this idea of making money in the short
term and we should embrace the idea of
creating sustainability and a long term
true conservatives should be conserving
natural resources and thinking about
downstream generations
right now we have hungry greedy people
who whose morals have been hijacked for
whatever reason and I think that this
this nature loving movement with all of
its strange you know characterizations
yeah it really is based on something
that's fundamentally good for the
Commons well it makes me think of what
you said at the very beginning or
certainly in the earlier portions of
this conversation which is the war
against nature is a war against your own
biology and ultimately what is best for
what you're discussing is also best for
us which means it's best for me it's
best for you it's best for each person
listening to this and certainly if
you're thinking out multiple generations
these problems can be solved in a very
pragmatic holistic fashion or they can
be compounded to the point where they
become exponentially more difficult to
unwind and to solve for so that's in the
field of my call I just want to say in
the field of my ecology I've known no
other science that is underfunded
underappreciated and yet has such an
enormous elasticity of benefits and if I
was a Bill Gates or Jeff Bezos you know
I met these people it's not part of my
DNA to pitch and I look at them going I
could do so much benefit for hundreds of
millions of people but I can't even
begin to talk about this because I don't
want to
but thankfully my company is soaring and
I've great group community of
individuals who are who believe in this
who see the results and Michael Pollan's
book and fantastic fungi and you know
you're you're in support etc it's helped
spread this message but you know I'm 63
years of age and I'm gonna die with a
smile on my face because it's the
heritage that we leave not not the
material possessions that we own during
a short lifetime we all need to create
legacies there were our names will be
heralded in the future as a person who
cared more about other people than they
cared about themselves that is truly a
Christian a Buddhist a zen-like attitude
and I think that it's time for people to
take action we need a revolution it is
time this time for people to take action
I could not agree more and you've given
a number of recommendations that I will
link to in the show notes as usual so
everyone listening every everything
we've discussed all the links to
everything certainly that I can track
down and that my team can track down
will be in the show notes at Tim top log
forward slash podcast for this episode
and Paul you've been very generous with
your time people can find you at fungi
calm fungi net host defense calm and on
social media on Instagram your Paul
Stamets Facebook Paul Stamets YouTube
Paul Stamets is there a a for people who
want to know where to go for what is
there one best place for certain things
a certain best place to say hello if
people want to reach out to you somehow
that's complicated like you Tim you know
we get so many people why in the contact
us but but I want to feed some of the
researchers out there and people who
want to get into some of the detailed
research articles we have a website that
we populate called mushroom reefs or
mushroom references calm mushroom
references calm eye several hundred
peer-reviewed articles that we link to
with abstracts that talk about the most
recent research of the from my
William and as a deep dive many
physicians are unfamiliar and because
the public expects that there would be
experts about everything on health
they're actually quite ignorant and so I
found this has been a challenge is why I
speak to a lot of academic conferences
that a lot of medical conferences is
that there is a desperate need by these
physicians to get on board and be
familiarized with some of the latest
research so but otherwise you know fungi
calm is a hub and we have a resource
section at the end on that website that
links to many other nonprofits lots of
other resources including Cornell
University that's particularly a good
one there is micro web which is
extremely good my K o w eb michael webb
is a really good one and so there's a
lot of mycologist out there that are
genuinely really really good people but
they have I've in a sense have tasked
them with expectations greater than some
of which they can deliver and I
apologize for that but time is short
this every is so important that
everybody gets to board the starship and
and try to do good well I thank you so
much for your time today Paul this has
been really fun for me and I'm sure for
for many many people who are listening
is there anything else that you would
like to share or recommend before we
wrap up at least this this first
conversation on the podcast if you see
somebody being abused or somebody being
shamed step up extend a hand of
generosity and show people a better way
of acting here here so that is an
excellent way to wrap up and once again
Paul a real pleasure to spend this time
with you I have pages and pages and
pages of notes follow-ups for myself and
for my family and also the many
different avenues that I want to explore
and to everyone listening you find the
show notes to end up blog /pha
and until next time keep experimenting
and express some kindness it is time to
take action so get off of the earphones
get off of the earbuds get off of the
pages in those books that you might
consume one after the other and actually
tape him take a meaningful step forward
with with somehow bending the reality
around you in a positive direction and
until next time thanks for listening hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all is
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible which has the largest selection
of audiobooks on the planet I've used
audible for many years and I have
several audio books to recommend right
off the bat if you're looking for a new
one ready player one by Ernest Cline you
may have heard of it the town of Seneca
by Seneca if you want to hear my
favorite collection of letters of all
time as well as the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman which is a fiction book I
used to reintroduce nonfiction purists
to the beauty and truth and enjoyment of
fiction graveyard book it is incredible
and I like the version that Neil reads
himself but the entire ensemble cast is
also fun audible members get a credit
every month good for any audiobook you
the
store regardless of price and unused
credits roll over to the next month so
if you didn't like your audiobook no
problem
you can exchange it no questions asked
plus your books are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and relist in
anytime even if you cancel your
membership and for some books again
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman I've
listened many many times you may even
just start over as soon as you finish it
the first time audible also helps you to
listen to more books by letting you
switch seamlessly between devices
picking up exactly where you left off
whether it's on your phone through your
car from the tablet for at home on
Amazon echo whatever you can get through
tons of books hands and eyes free while
doing almost anything so that is part of
the beauty of audio it is a secondary
activity when you are walking the dog
cooking whatever it might be audible
content includes an unmatched selection
of audiobooks original audio shows news
comedy and much more from leading audio
book publishers broadcasters
entertainers magazine and newspaper
publishers and business information
providers maybe that's what I am a
business information provider and right
now audible is offering listeners of
this podcast a free audio book with a
30-day trial memberships check it out go
to audible.com forward slash tim and
browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs download a title free and start
listening is super simple
good audible.com forward slash tim or
text tim to 500 500 on your key phone to
get started today check it out this
episode is brought to you by peloton
which I've been using probably for about
a year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
can also do on demand which is what I do
we'll come back to that so you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
a busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute I for instance have a peloton
bike right in my master bedroom at home
and it's one of the first things I do
many mornings I wake up I meditate for a
bit then I knock out a short 20 minute
ride in my undies hard to do that at the
gym take a shower and I'm in higher gear
for the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep
motivated they're also up to 14 new
classes at it every day with more than
8,000 classes on demand and you can pick
based on length 45 minutes 20 minutes
whatever music hip-hop rock and roll or
say low impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I quite like Matt woofers
and I tend to do on-demand and listen to
a lot of and watch many of the same
classes over and over but I'm kind of
promiscuous and also enjoy classes from
a lot of the other instructors they have
peloton an amazing roster of incredible
instructors in New York City with a
whole range of styles and personalities
so you can find what you're in the mood
for you also get real-time metrics that
you can use to track your performance
over time and that will help I would say
catalyze you to beat your personal best
now that all sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way and Santa buys me but they
really 100% hit the nail on the head I
was very very impressed with how
motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out discover
this cutting-edge indoor cycling bike
that brings a studio experience right to
your home peloton is offering listeners
of this podcast a limited time offer go
to one peloton comm that's fo and e
peloton PE L OTO and calm and enter the
code Tim all caps at checkout and get
$100 off of accessories with your Paula
so Mike purchase so get a great workout
of home anytime you want check it out go
to one peloton calm and use the code Tim
to get started
you
you